♪
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: TO THE
GRADUATES OF THE CLASS OF 2020 -
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE CLASS OF
2021 - AND THEIR PARENTS,
FAMILIES, AND FRIENDS, HERE AND
ONLINE: WELCOME BACK TO YALE!
[ APPLAUSE ]
TODAY, WE GATHER TWO YEARS AFT
YOU EARNED YOUR DEGREES TO
RECOGNIZE YOUR EXTRAORDINARY AC.
YOU MADE SACRIFICES.
YOU OVERCAME ADVERSITY.
YOU PERSEVERED.
THIS CEREMONY, DELAYED BY A
HISTORICAL GLOBAL DISRUPTION, I
ALL THE MORE MEANINGFUL AND
JOYOUS BECAUSE OF YOUR HARD WOR
AND COMMITMENT TO THE COMMON GO.
WE SALUTE YOUR EFFORTS, YOUR
DILIGENCE, YOUR INTELLECT, AND
YOUR RESILIENCE.
WE ALSO JOIN YOU IN EXPRESSING
GRATITUDE FOR ALL WHO HAVE
SUPPORTED YOU IN THESE
ENDEAVORS: YOUR FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS, TEACHERS, AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE YALE COMMUNITY.
IN KEEPING WITH THE TRADITION
THIS OCCASION, I NOW CALL ON TH
UNIVERSITY CHAPLAIN TO OFFER AN.
CHAPLAIN KUGLER:
MY HEART IS SO FULL TO LOOK AT
YOU.
WITH DEEP GRATITUDE TO THE
QUINNIPIAC PEOPLE FOR THIS LAND
ON WHICH WE STAND, MY BELOVED
YALE FAMILY, I INVITE YOU TO
JOIN IN ME IN THE SPIRIT OF PRA.
ALMIGHTY AND LOVING CREATOR, Y
ARE THE FORCE THAT LIGHTS THE
STARS, THE ARCHITECT OF EVERY
CELL, THE SOURCE OF ALL TRUTH.
WE LOOK TO YOU AS MANY
EXPRESSIONS OF ONE LIVING
MYSTERY, A MYSTERY THAT IS
BEYOND ALL TELLING.
IN THIS MOMENT OF RETURN AND
REUNION, OUR HEARTS BEAT
DIFFERENTLY FOR ALL THAT WE HAV
BEEN THROUGH.
WE WHO SHARE THIS BEAUTIFUL, B
ACHING WORLD, WE WHO LOOK AT TH
SAME SUN AND THE SAME MOON, ARE
A PEOPLE CALLED TO COMMUNAL RES.
RESILIENCY ORATION.
AS STUDENTS OF YOUR HANDIWORK
GATHERED AT YALE FROM THROUGHOU
THE EARTH WITH EXQUISITE
AMBITIONS AND HAVE BEEN BLESSED
AT THIS PLACE OF LIGHT AND TRUT
WITH THE FREEDOM TO LET THEM GR.
FRO.
OUR GOD OF ALL GENERATIONS, YO
ARE THE GUARDIAN OF WHERE WE AR
GOING AND WHO WE ARE BECOMING.
WE ARE FILLED WITH GRATITUDE F
OUR FAMILIES, FRIENDS, TEACHERS,
CAN AND GUIDES.
THEIR ARMS HAVE SHELTERED US,
THEIR SHOULDERS HAVE BOOSTED US
AND TODAY THEIR HEARTS ARE
HOLDING FAST TO US.
BLESS US AS WE SEEK TO REIMAGI
A WORLD MADE BETTER BY THE
CONSIDERABLE GIFTS WE ARE
BRINGING TO IT, MAY WE EXUDE AN
INTELLIGENCE THAT IS INSPIRED B
JUSTICE, GUIDED BY TENDERNESS,
MOVED BY HOLINESS AND ALWAYS
INFORMED BY LOVE.
AS WE CONTINUE TO GREET
TOMORROW, STEADY US ON SOLID
GROUND AND TOGETHER MAY WE
BECOME VIBRANT LIVING EXAMPLES
OF SHALOM, OF SALAAM, OF SHANTI,
OF PEACE.
FOR THIS WE SAY, AMEN.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY:
PLEASE BE SEATED.
GRADUATES OF THE CLASS OF 2020
AND THE CLASS OF 2021, FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS.
IT'S RARE FOR A UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENT TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK FORMALLY
WITH YOU TWICE TO CELEBRATE YOUR
GRADUATION.
LOOKING AT ALL OF YOU NOW AND
KNOWING SO MANY ARE ALSO WITH U
ONLINE, I AM DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE CHANCE TO DO SO.
NONE OF US COULD HAVE PREDICTE
WHEN WE FIRST MET AT YOUR
OPENING ASSEMBLIES THAT THE
CULMINATION OF YOUR "BRIGHT
COLLEGE YEARS" WOULD COINCIDE
WITH THE ONSET OF A
ONCE-IN-A-GENERATION PANDEMIC.
YOU GAVE UP BIG MOMENTS AND
MISSED OUT ON QUIETER ONES.
BUT THE CHALLENGES POSED BY TH
COVID-19 PANDEMIC DID NOT DEFINE
YOUR TIME AT YALE.
INSTEAD, YOU ARE REMEMBERED FO
YOUR COMPASSION, STRENGTH, AND
CHARACTER.
FORMER UNIVERSITY PRESIDENT
KINGMAN BREWSTER JR. ONCE
DISTILLED THE SELECTION OF OUR
FUTURE STUDENTS AS A
"COMBINATION OF LOOKING FOR
THOSE WITH A ZEST TO STRETCH th
LIMITS OF THEIR TALENTS, AND
THOSE WITH AN OUTSTANDING PUBLIC
MOTIVATION."
INDEED, IT WAS WITH THIS
OUTSTANDING PUBLIC MOTIVATION
THAT YOU ACCOMMODATED WHAT THIS
MOMENT IN HISTORY ASKED OF YOU.
AND IT WAS WITH THIS ZEST TO
STRETCH THE LIMITS OF YOUR
TALENTS THAT YOU ASKED HOW YOU
COULD SERVE OTHERS.
OF COURSE, COMMENCEMENT WEEKEN
ARE TRADITIONALLY OCCASIONS FOR
THOSE OF US ON THE PLATFORM TO
IMPART WISDOM AS GRADUATES
PREPARE TO ENTER THE WORLD.
YET AS MEMBERS OF THE CLASS OF
2020 AND 2021, YOU HAVE FLIPPED
THIS PROPOSITION ENTIRELY.
YOU ARE NO ORDINARY GROUP OF
GRADUATES.
AND THIS IS NO ORDINARY
CEREMONY.
SO, INSTEAD, WE GATHER TODAY T
COMMEMORATE ALL YOU TAUGHT US.
WE GATHER TODAY TO APPLAUD YOU
MASTERCLASS IN RESILIENCE AND IN
RESOLVE.
CLASS OF 2020, YOU MAY RECALL
THAT AT YOUR OPENING ASSEMBLY,
CONCLUDED MY REMARKS WITH AN
EXPRESSION OF CONFIDENCE THAT
YOU WOULD, ON YOUR "FIRST DAY O
SCHOOL," "BEGIN IMMEDIATELY TO
SEEK OUT WHAT IS BEST ABOUT THI
PLACE: THE FACULTY AND STAFF AN
PEERS WHO WILL BOTH INSPIRE YOU
AND PREPARE YOU TO BECOME THE
INVESTIGATORS, VISIONARIES, AND
LEADERS THE WORLD SO SORELY
NEEDS."
"NONE OF US HERE CAN HOPE FOR
BETTER WORLD, OR EVEN FOR A MOR
INCLUSIVE AND EXHILARATING
LEARNING COMMUNITY AT YALE," I
CONTINUED, "UNLESS WE SUCCEED AT
THIS MISSION.
YOU ARE IN FACT WHAT GIVES US
HOPE."
THAT WAS SIX YEARS AGO.
NOW, ON THIS CEREMONIAL "LAST
DAY OF SCHOOL," YOU ARE STILL A
SOURCE OF HOPE.
NOT ONLY BECAUSE WE SUCCEEDED AT
OUR MISSION, BUT ALSO BECAUSE
YOU SUCCEEDED AT YOURS.
NOT MERELY BECAUSE YOU SOUGHT
OUT WHAT IS BEST ABOUT THIS
PLACE WHEN YOU ARRIVED, BUT
BECAUSE YOU EXEMPLIFIED IT WHEN
YOU LEFT.
IN HIS BOOK, THE DIGNITY OF
DIFFERENCE, THE LATE RABBI LORD
JONATHAN SACKS-WHO WAS AWARDED
AN HONORARY DEGREE FROM
YALE-DESCRIBES A SUBTLE, YET
INSIGHTFUL DISTINCTION BETWEEN
OPTIMISM AND HOPE.
"OPTIMISM," HE WRITES, "IS THE
BELIEF THAT THINGS WILL GET
BETTER."
"HOPE," MEANWHILE, "IS THE FAI
THAT, TOGETHER, WE CAN MAKE
THINGS BETTER.
OPTIMISM IS A PASSIVE VIRTUE,
HOPE AN ACTIVE ONE.
IT TAKES NO COURAGE TO BE AN
OPTIMIST," RABBI SACKS ASSERTS.
"BUT IT TAKES A GREAT DEAL OF
COURAGE TO HAVE HOPE."
OVER THE LAST TWO OR MORE years
SOMBER REALITIES AROUND THE
WORLD HAVE THREATENED TO
DIMINISH OUR SENSE OF OPTIMISM.
BUT YOUR RESPONSE TO THESE
CRISES HAS PROVIDED REASON FOR
HOPE.
WITH A GREAT DEAL OF COURAGE,
YOU HAVE BOTH BELIEVED IN A
BETTER WORLD AND WORKED TOWARD
IT.
CRISIS HAS CATALYZED THE
PROGRESS IT COULD HAVE
HAMSTRUNG.
I THINK, FOR INSTANCE, OF
MARGARET KELLOGG, A 2020
GRADUATE OF YALE COLLEGE AND
CURRENT MEMBER OF THE
SALIVADIRECT TEAM.
AT THE OUTSET OF THE PANDEMIC,
HER YALE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALT
COLLEAGUES BEGAN WORK ON
EASY-TO-COLLECT, LOW-COST,
HIGH-QUALITY PCR TESTS TO DEPLO
IN COMMUNITIES, SCHOOL
DISTRICTS, AND BUSINESSES ACROSS
AMERICA.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATOR ANNE
WYLLIE, MILLIONS OF SALIVADIREC
TESTS HAVE BEEN ADMINISTERED.
AND THE INITIATIVE IS A
BLUEPRINT FOR HOW SOCIETY
IMPROVES ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
INFECTIOUS DISEASE TESTING.
I THINK, TOO, OF MARGARET'S
CLASSMATES, CHRISTINA PAO AND
PAUL GROSS, HER CLASSMATES.
CHRISTINA SAYS THE INEQUITIES
MADE MORE VISIBLE BY THE
PANDEMIC STOKED AN EXISTING
AMBITION TO "MAKE THE WORLD A
FAIRER PLACE."
SHE HAS SINCE LAUNCHED A
RESEARCH PROJECT TO EXAMINE THE
HAUNTING RISE OF XENOPHOBIA.
AND PAUL'S START-UP TO CAPTURE
CARBON EMISSIONS FROM
SEMI-TRUCKS WAS FOUNDED DURING
THE EARLIEST STAGES OF THE
PANDEMIC.
NEITHER PAUL NOR THE GLOBAL
CRISIS HE IS COMBATTING COULD
WAIT FOR THE RETURN OF IN-PERSON
OPERATIONS.
AS I LOOK OUT ON OLD CAMPUS, I
SEE A FORCE FOR PROGRESS AND
POSITIVE CHANGE.
LEADERS WHO STEPPED UP AT A
CRITICAL TIME TO HELP NOURISH
THE HUNGRY, ENSURE THE MOST
VULNERABLE HAD ACCESS TO
ESSENTIAL SERVICES, AND COLLECT
PPE FOR FRONTLINE WORKERS.
I SEE IN YOU, SIMPLY, THE
COMPASSION OF THE HUMAN SPIRIT.
MEMBERS OF THE CLASS OF 2020 AD
THE CLASS OF 2021:  YOU HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THE CALL TO
SERVE SOCIETY INSCRIBED IN OUR
FOUNDING DOCUMENT CAN ENDURE.
AND INDEED CAN BE IGNITED BY
HARDSHIP.
YOU HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT YAL
IN THE END, IS NOT ITS OLDEST
BOOKS OR ITS NEWEST
LABORATORIES.
IT IS NOT EVEN THE SUM OF ITS
SWEEPING GOTHIC BUILDINGS AND
THEIR SHARP MODERNIST
COMPLEMENTS.
YOU HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT YAL
IS SIMPLY US AND OUR BEST EFFOR
TO REALIZE OUR MISSION TO
IMPROVE THE WORLD TODAY AND FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
BY FORCE OF AN EMERGENCY, WE A
HAD TO PURSUE THAT MISSION
DIFFERENTLY.
BUT WE WORKED TOGETHER AS A
COMMUNITY TO PURSUE IT WITH
CONVICTION.
YOU HAVE MY DEEPEST APPRECIATI
FOR THE SELFLESSNESS WITH WHICH
YOU SAFEGUARDED PUBLIC HEALTH A
A STUDENT AND FOR THE TENACITY
WITH WHICH YOU HAVE WORKED TO
REPAIR OUR WORLD AS A GRADUATE.
MORE THAN FOR HAVING YOUR
COLLEGE YEARS COINCIDE WITH A
PANDEMIC AT ITS WORST, YOU WILL
BE REMEMBERED FOR REPRESENTING
YALE AT ITS BEST.
MORE THAN REINVIGORATING OUR
OPTIMISM, YOU HAVE ALLOWED US
THE COURAGE TO HOPE.
TODAY WE SALUTE YOUR SACRIFICE.
SACRIFICE THAT HAS SOLIDIFIED
YOUR RIGHTFUL PLACE IN HISTORY.
AND WE WILL CELEBRATE YOUR
DISPLAY OF HIGH MORAL PURPOSE
THAT WILL BUILD THE FUTURE WE
ALL SO DESIRE.
GRADUATIONS!
[ APPLAUSE ]
IT IS NOW MY PRIVILEGE TO CALL
ON YOUR DEANS TO PRESENT
CONGRATULATIONS FROM YOUR
SCHOOLS.
DEAN CHUN: MR. PRESIDENT, I HA
THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE GRADUATE
FOR THE BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN
YALE COLLEGE: FOR THE DEGREE OF
BACHELOR OF ARTS
.
931 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF BACHELOR
OF SCIENCE.
463 IN NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE AS DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
DEAN BERKE: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF ARCHITECTURE: FOR THE
DEGREE OF MASTER OF ARCHITECTURE
.
137 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE MASTER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DESIGN, 5 IN
NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
DEGREES IN ARCHITECTURE AND
DESIGN AS DESIGNATED BY THE DEA
AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THAT'S YOU.
YES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN PINDER: MR. PRESIDENT, I
TOGETHER WITH DEAN KIMBERLY
PINDER HAVE THE HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE GRADUATES FOR DEGREES
IN THE SCHOOL OF ART.
ING FOR THE AGREE OF MASTER IN
FINE ARTS, 61 IN NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
DEGREE IN ART AS DESIGNATED BY
THE DEAN AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL
ITS RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN BUNDY: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
DAVID GEFFEN SCHOOL OF DRAMA:
FOR THE CERTIFICATE IN DRAMA
, 4 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF FINE
ARTS, 62 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
FINE ARTS, 1 IN NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
CERTIFICATE AND DEGREES IN DRAM
AS DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND
ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN BLOCKER: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF MUSIC: FOR THE
CERTIFICATE IN PERFORMANCE
, 2 IN NUMBER.
BETTER ARTIST DIPLOMA, 3 IN
NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE MASTER OF MUSIC,
138 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
MUSICAL ARTS, 77 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
MUSICAL ARTS, 12 IN NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
CERTIFICATE, DIPLOMA, AND
DEGREES IN MUSIC AS DESIGNATED
BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT YOU TO AL
THEIR RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITI.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN KURTH: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF NURSING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
SCIENCE IN NURSING, 238 IN
NUMBER.
FOR THE POST-MASTER'S
CERTIFICATE IN NURSING, 2 IN
NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
NURSING PRACTICE, 33 IN NUMBER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY:  BY THE
AUTHORITY INVESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
DEGREES AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL OF
THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN BURKE: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF THE ENVIRONMENT: FOR
THE --
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
FORESTRY, 21 IN NUMBER.
FOREST SCIENCE, 2 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL MANAGEMENT, 196 IN
NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE, 38 IN
NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
DEGREES IN FORESTRY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES AS
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMI
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN CHARLES: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF MANAGEMENT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION, 758 IN
NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ADVANCED MANAGEMENT, 118 IN
NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER IN
MANAGEMENT STUDIES, 123 IN
NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
DEGREES IN MANAGEMENT AS
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMI
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
DEAN STERLING: MR. PRESIDENT,
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
DIVINITY SCHOOL.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF ARTS
IN RELIGION, 142 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
DIVINITY, 122 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
SACRED THEOLOGY, 22 IN NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
DEGREES IN RELIGION, DIVINITY,
AND THEOLOGY AS DESIGNATED BY
THE DEAN AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL
THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> BRAVO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN GERKEN: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR DEGREES IN THE LAW
SCHOOL.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
LAWS, 28 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTERS OF
STUDIES IN LAW, 2 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF THE
SCIENCE OF LAW, 12 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF JURIS
DOCTOR, 420 IN NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREE BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
DEGREES IN THE LAW SCHOOL AS
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMI
YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN COOLEY: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
GRADUATE SCHOOL: FOR THE DEGREE
OF MASTER OF ADVANCED STUDY
, 52 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
SCIENCE, 109 IN NUMBER.
ARTS, 95 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
ARTS, 95 IN NUMBER.
PHILOSOPHY, 717 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
PHILOSOPHY, 717 IN NUMBER.
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
DEGREES IN THE GRADUATE SCHOOL
MY HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
AS DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND
DEGREES IN THE GRADUATE SCHOOL
ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS
AS DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
ADMIT YOU TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN VERMUND: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR THE DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, 207 IN NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT IS MY
HONOR TO CONFER UPON YOU THE
DEGREES IN PUBLIC HEALTH AS
DESIGNATED BY THE DEAN AND ADMIT
YOU TO ALL ITS RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN BROWN: MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
GRADUATES FOR DEGREES IN THE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE: FOR THE
DEGREE OF MASTER OF MEDICAL
SCIENCE, 78 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE CERTIFICATE IN GLOBAL
MEDICINE, 1 IN NUMBER.
FOR THE DEGREE OF MASTER OF
HEALTH SCIENCE, 35 IN NUMBER.
AND FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
MEDICINE, 112 IN NUMBER.
THEY WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
FACULTY OF THE SCHOOL AND
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
AND THEY WERE CONFERRED THEIR
DEGREES BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: BY THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME, IT WAS
MY HONOR TO CONFER THE DEGREE I
MEDICAL SCIENCE AND THE
CERTIFICATE AND DEGREES IN
GLOBAL MEDICINE, HEALTH SCIENCE
AND MEDICINE AS DESIGNATED BY
THE DEAN AND ADMIT YOU TO ALL
THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN COOLEY: PRAESES CLARISSIM
CANDIDATOS AD GRADUM
PHILOSOPHIAE DOCTORIS, NUMERO
-- TE ANIMADVERTERE VELIM. A
FACULTATE PHILOSOPHIAE ARTIUMQU
ET AB SENATU ACADEMICO ILLUSTRI
APPROBATI SUNT. TE, DOMINE, ROG
UT EOS AD HUNC GRADUM ADMITTAS.
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: SECUNDUM
LEGES MOREMQUE UNIVERSITATIS
NOSTRAE, VOS AD GRADUM
PHILOSOPHIAE DOCTORIS ADMISI,
VOBISQUE UNA CUM HOC DIPLOMATE,
IURA ILLA ATQUE DIGNITATES, QUA
AD HUNC HONOREM SPECTANT
CONTULI. NUNC, STUDIIS FELICITE
ABSOLUTIS, EGO, PRAESES
UNIVERITATIS, VOS EX ANIMO IUB
SALVERE ET VALERE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
PLEASE RISE.
♪
♪ THY PRAISE ALONE, O LORD, DOTH
REIGN IN SION THAT'S FINE OWN
HILL ♪
♪ THEIR VOWS TO THEE THEY DO
MAINTAIN AND EVERMORE FULFILL ♪
♪ FOR THAT THOU DOST THEIR PRAY
'RS STILL HEAR AND DOST THERETO
AGREE ♪
♪ THY PEOPLE ALL BOTH FAR AND
NEAR WITH TRUST SHALL COME TO
THEE ♪
♪ OF THY GREAT JUSTICE HEAR O
GOD OUR HEALTH OF THEE DOTH RISE
♪
♪ THE HOPE OF ALL THE EARTH
ABROAD AND THE SEA-COASTS
LIKEWISE ♪
♪ WE DEDICATE OUR LIVES ANEW
THAT LIGHT AND TRUTH WILL SHINE
♪
♪ THROUGHOUT THE WORLD, O GOD,
WE PRAY, TO ALL OF HUMANKIND ♪
PRESIDENT SALOVEY:  PLEASE BE
SEATED.
WE WILL NOW PROCEED TO RECOGNIZE
THE RECIPIENTS OF THE 2020
HONORARY DEGREES.
THE TRADITION OF AWARDING
HONORARY DEGREES AT YALE BEGAN
IN 1702.
HONORARY DEGREES ARE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT RECOGNITION
CONFERRED BY THE YALE
CORPORATION, THE UNIVERSITY'S
BOARD OF TRUSTEES, TO SIGNAL
PIONEERING ACHIEVEMENT IN A
FIELD OR CONSPICUOUS AND
EXEMPLARY CONTRIBUTION TO THE
COMMON GOOD.
HONORARY DEGREE RECIPIENTS SERVE
AS EXAMPLES TO ALL GRADUATES,
ENCOURAGING YOU TO ASPIRE TO
EXCELLENCE AND TO VALUE THOSE
ELEMENTS OF HUMAN CHARACTER THAT
THEY EMBODY.
CREATIVITY, CURIOSITY,
DISCIPLINE, INTEGRITY, AND A
PASSION FOR PUBLIC SERVICE.
THOSE WHO RECEIVE HONORARY
DEGREES REPRESENT COLLECTIVELY
THE ASPIRATIONS OF THIS
INSTITUTION.
WE ARE PLEASED TO HONOR IN
PERSON TODAY ONE RECIPIENT AND
TO RECOGNIZE THE HONORANDS WHO
ARE NOT WITH US TODAY.
AND I WILL NOW CALL, AS IS
CUSTOMARY, UPON THE PROVOST TO
PRESENT THE 2020 HONORARY
DEGREES.
PROVOST STROBEL:  MR. PRESIDENT,
FOR THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
ENGINEERING AND TECHNOLOGY.
MICHAEL I. JORDAN, COMPUTER
SCIENTIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT SALOVEY: FACING AN
UNCERTAIN AND COMPLEX WORLD, YO
HARNESS THE POWER OF HUMAN AND
MACHINE LEARNING TO SOLVE
DAUNTING PROBLEMS.
BY BRIDGING DISCIPLINES AND
FOLLOWING YOUR CURIOSITY, YOU
HAVE MADE POSSIBLE WHAT WAS ONCE
ONLY IMAGINED.
EXPLORER OF NEW DOMAINS,
CHAMPION OF BIG IDEAS: IN
RECOGNITION OF THE DOORS YOU
HAVE OPENED AND THE NETWORKS YOU
HAVE BUILT, WE ARE PROUD TO
BESTOW ON YOU THE DOCTOR OF
ENGINEERING AND TECHNOLOGY
DEGREE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
IT IS ALSO OUR PLEASURE TO
RECOGNIZE THE 2020 HONORARY
DEGREE RECIPIENTS WHO ARE NOT
WITH US TODAY.
PROVOST STROBEL:
JIM ALLISON, IMMUNOLOGIST.
[ APPLAUSE ]
JEROME ALAN COHEN, LEGAL
SCHOLAR.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CHRISTIANA FIGUERES, PUBLIC
SERVANT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
RENÉE FLEMING, SOPRANO.
HERBIE HANCOCK, MUSICIAN AND
[ APPLAUSE ]
COMPOSER.
HERBIE HANCOCK, MUSICIAN AND
[ APPLAUSE ]
COMPOSER.
MING CHO LEE, THEATRICAL SET
[ APPLAUSE ]
DESIGNER.
MING CHO LEE, THEATRICAL SET
[ APPLAUSE ]
DESIGNER.
SVANTE PÄÄBO, EVOLUTIONARY
[ APPLAUSE ]
GENETICIST.
SVANTE PÄÄBO, EVOLUTIONARY
PAULA VOGEL, PLARIGHT AND
GENETICIST.
EDUCATEOR.
PAULA VOGEL, PLARIGHT AND
[ APPLSE
EDUCATEOR.
PRIDTALEY: HA YOU,
[ APPLSE
. OVOST.
PRIDTALEY: HA YOU,
PLSE .
. OVOST.
♪
♪ LET LIGHT AND TRUTH SUFFUSE
THE MIND ♪
♪ AND SPREAD THROUGHOUT OUR
SHADOWED HEART ♪
♪ AS WHAT WE KNOW IS REDEFINED ♪
♪ THROUGH SCIENCE, SCHOLARSHIP,
AND ART ♪
♪ OUR FOUNDERS KNEW THAT FAITH
REQUIRES ♪
♪ THE DISCIPLINE OF STURDY
THOUGHT ♪
♪ THEY TRUSTED THAT THE SPIRIT'S
FIRES ♪
♪ BURN BRIGHTEST WHERE THE TRUTH
IS SOUGHT ♪
♪ WE'VE LEARNED THE WISEST
PRAYER THEY PRAYED ♪
♪ WAS THAT "MORE LIGHT" WOULD
GUIDE THEIR WAYS ♪
♪ FOR WE, LIKE THEM, HAVE BEEN
REMAID ♪
♪ BY UNEXPECTED, SLANTED RAYS ♪
♪ SO LET THE GIFT OF GATHERED
LIGHT ♪
♪ PERVADE THE WAYS WE LEARN AND
KNOW ♪
♪ AWAKING WONDER AND DELIGHT ♪
♪ WHILE KNOWLEDGE, TRUTH, AND
WISDOM GROW ♪
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEAN STERLING:
PRAY WITH ME AS WE CLOSE THIS
COMMENCEMENT.
GOD OF PARADOX, UNKNOWABLE IN
BEING, BUT KNOWN BY EXPERIENCE;
UNLIMITED BY DIMENSIONS, BUT
PRESENT IN TIME AND SPACE;
UNCHANGING, BUT MOVED BY THE
SUFFERINGS OF ALL.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESERVATION
OF LIFE IN THE MIDST OF DEATH.
FOR COMMUNITY IN THE WAKE OF
ISOLATION.
FOR THE JUBILATION OF AN
EMBODIED COMMENCEMENT.
GIVE THESE WE CELEBRATE THE
DARING TO ATTEMPT WHAT SEEMS
IMPOSSIBLE.
THE CAPACITY TO PERCEIVE WHAT
APPEARS UNKNOWABLE.
THE INTEGRITY TO ACT ON
PRINCIPLE WHERE NO MORAL COMPASS
IS DISCERNIBLE.
BLESS THE FAMILIES THAT HAVE
GIVEN THESE CELEBRANTS THEIR
PAST.
THIS UNIVERSITY THAT HAS SHAPED
THEIR PRESENT.
AND BLESS THESE CELEBRANTS WHO
WILL SHAPE THE FUTURE FOR US
ALL.
AMEN.
♪